at this pub as well as pulling pints the
staff are also trained to save lives
it's one of the first late-night venues
in the City of London to receive a bleed
control kit designed to help those
who've been stabbed or shot we've got a
torniquet a wide taller K this would
tighten up around the limb more than 300
kits are being handed out by the police
here following a successful pilot in
firming him earlier this year they
contain a whole host of medical supplies
all designed to treat catastrophic
bleeding bottom line is people are being
injured across the country violent crime
is up enough as I said this is a no
brainer and to not do anything would be
the travesty this is a really really
simple piece of kit which working
together effectively with with local
authority and our licensed premises will
hopefully save life last year the amount
of knife crime recorded by the police
hit a record high with 44,000 offences
in England and Wales and NHS data shows
the number of people going to hospital
with blade injuries as was in by a third
over five years I just remember Jimmy's
beautiful smile Margaret and Barry
missins son Jimmy was murdered in a
bakery in southeast London more than a
decade ago they're welcoming the new
initiative this is not a panacea to
solve knife crime the idea really is to
try and stop so many people dying and if
it prevents even one person from losing
their life because of this kit then I
can't think that being a bad thing place
the non-adherent pad over the wound and
wrap tightly the 25,000 pound cost of
buying the kits in London is being
covered by a levy on bars and clubs open
past midnight if it proves successful
it's hoped the model could be replicated
across the country putting a piece of
potentially life-saving equipment within
easily
Rachel Sky News